Therefore, when we have this test statistic that measures whether or not there
are significant differences between three or more samples. We have to construct
this statistic so that as within-group variability increases the test statistic
decreases. Becomes more in favor of the null, meaning that the sample means are
less likely to be different from each other. And this statistic should also
take into account that as between group variability increases, the test
statistic increases. The sample means are more likely to be different from each
other. We can do this by making a test statistic. Let's call it f. A ratio of
the between group variability and within group variability. Which should be in
the numerator, and which should be in the denominator?